All right guys, so we've chosen a niche.
We're not going to overthink it.
If you don't know, just going back to what we talked about before, choose concrete.
If you're going to be analysis paralysis and delay choosing, just choose concrete.
Okay?
So we've chosen the niche, we've done our keyword research, and now it's time to go
and find the city.
I don't want you to overthink this too much, but I also want you to understand how important
it is that we do this correctly.
This is where all the money is made and also, unfortunately, where all the money is lost.
All right, so guys, the very first thing we're going to do is we're going to go and get a
tool that shows us demand, shows us search volume.
And for some of you that chose Ahrefs or Mangools or SEMrush or any of these things, it doesn't
matter.
Okay?
And I'm going to explain why.
So let me just show you this really quick.
All right.
So this, I'm going to show you guys SEMrush, SEMrush.com, SEMrush, it is a little bit more
expensive tool.
It's just something I've been using for years and years and years.
I'm just going to use it.
You can use any tool.
And I want to stress the importance to you guys that tools do not tell the truth.
Okay?
These tools are not accurate.
Let me repeat that.
And so you're not going to take these at face value.
The reason that we're using tools is we want to look at comparisons.
Okay?
We want to see, all right, for example, we have, maybe there's a project that you've
done in Minnesota, Minnesota Tree Service or Minnesota Concrete, okay?
Or not Minnesota, sorry, Minneapolis, Minneapolis Concrete, Minneapolis Tree Service.
And you can then in your head, let's say you've ranked that website, you're in the maps, everything's
fine and dandy.
And you can look at the tools, let's say you're using Mangools.
Well, Mangools tells you that there's only, you know, 50 people searching for Tree Service
in Minneapolis and you're ranked number one and you're ranked number one in the maps and
you're getting a hundred calls a month.
So therefore we can infer or we can interpret that if Mangools tells us it's 50, it's probably
close to a hundred.
So I want to be very clear that these tools are not accurate.
The tool does not matter.
What matters, guys, is that we're consistent with the tool that we use.
Okay, so I'm going to use SEMROSH, SEMROSH, I don't even know how they say it, that's
how much I care about tools.
Just pick one, okay?
Don't overthink it.
If you want something free, use Google Keyword Planner, it's fine.
That's step one.
Step two is what we're going to do is we're going to take a project that you have ranked
number one in the maps for most of the top terms and number one organically, okay?
And that's for a couple of months.
Now some of you guys are going to go, well, I'm brand new to this, I've never done that.
If that is the case, or if you have other projects and you just want to make this easy,
I'm going to let you use one of mine to do the following exercise.
So what we're going to do is we're going to take a site that's been ranking for years
and we're going to in our heads go, okay, this site based on data has produced this
many leads.
So the site that we're going to use is the trusty old Bentonville Concrete, which I am
ranking top in the maps, top in the organic, and I've done this for years and years.
And this site has consistently produced between 20 and 35 leads pretty much every month for
the past three years, two and a half, three years, okay?
So what we want to do is we want to take your tool.
So let's, in my case, I'm going to use SEMrush, right?
So I'm going to go to SEMrush or SEMrush, I'm not even sure how to say it, and I'm going
to type in Bentonville Concrete, okay, and I'm going to see what it says.
So this tool tells me, it tells me there's 40 volume, okay?
In fact, let me go and check recently what we've gotten here, give me a second here.
Because what's, and this is going to be an interesting point, okay.
So let me just give you an example here.
It's June 14th at the time of recording this.
We got one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, literally one
a day, okay?
So we can pretty easily estimate that, you know, according to this, that's actually fairly
accurate.
Last month, we can go to May, well, this, you know, this is actually going to be changing
it.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18,
19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 35, 36, 37, 38, 39, 40,
41, 42, 43, 44, 45, 46, 47, 48, 49, 50, okay.
So here's a couple of interesting things.
Number one is this is not accurate because this has changed.
Just for the record, since I started doing this, this has changed.
The data has changed.
This part of the country has gotten a big influx of people.
There's a lot of building going on, huge building boom.
This didn't used to say 40, just so you know.
And also, you guys are going to laugh because this also used to be about $2 cost per click.
There's been a lot of people jump into the space.
There's been a lot of competitors, a lot of people running ads, and so this has changed.
But I still want you to see that even though this says 40, I'm actually getting more than
40 leads, okay.
I'm getting about 1.25 to every time it says 4.
So if this says 40, it's probably closer to 50, okay.
We can kind of assume based on this.
And if I want to check maybe one more month, you know, I could go and do that.
Look at April.
And I've got three pages.
That looks like it's a pretty accurate estimate.
We're probably getting 50 to 60 leads at this point.
And it's funny because that's how long it's been since I've checked it.
So we're going to just base, basically anything that SEM rush says, we're going to, and again,
this isn't perfect.
We're just going to assume that anything SEM rush says or SEM rush says, it's going to
be about 1.25 to whatever it says, okay.
So now we've got our baseline.
If you guys want to use my Bentonville concrete project as a baseline, great.
If you want to use something else, that's great.
The point is we want to find a ratio.
We want to see what it says with this one compared to another one.
And guys, if you have multiple projects, I would highly encourage you to look at this
on multiple projects so you can get a good baseline number so that, okay.
And you guys might type this into keyword planner and it's going to say 10.
And you're going to know, okay, every time it says 10, it's probably closer to 50, okay.
And that's what I want you guys to look at is we want to have that baseline.
We got to come up with that baseline ratio to say, okay, when it says this, it actually
is 1.25 of whatever it says, okay.
So that's step two.
Now let's get into the fun stuff, all right.
What I'm going to have you guys do now that we've gotten a baseline, which according to
SEMrush, you're going to use this, it's probably going to be about 1.25 to whatever it says.
I'm now going to go over to this little tool that's free.
It's called Google Trends, okay.
Step three.
We're going to go to Google Trends.
You're going to type it in, in your whatever search bar and click on it.
And what you're going to do is you're going to plug in your main keyword.
So I'm going to, and it doesn't need to be the main one, it could be a main one.
So let's just do concrete, do concrete contractors.
I would do concrete, but concrete also encompasses ready mix concrete, a bunch of different stuff,
people that do projects with concrete.
So I'm going to do concrete contractors because that's somebody that is most likely looking
for somebody to pour concrete, okay.
So that's what you're going to do is you're going to type in concrete contractors.
And what this tool is going to do is it's going to tell you what states have the highest
search volume in the United States for this specific term.
And by the way, you guys can use this in different countries, et cetera, okay.
So you're going to go, and this is how you're going to pick a state because what I don't
want you to do is look at a map and just throw a dart.
Now if you live in a city, and I do want to mention this really, really briefly.
This is a really important point.
Do not go into California, okay.
Do not go into California.
If you live in California and you're targeting your backyard or if you have projects already
that you've built, I don't want you to get discouraged.
You can still make money, but I'm telling you right now, there is a lot easier money
to make outside of California.
And this is coming from experience, from calling, cold calling, this is coming from experience
knocking doors.
This is coming from experience of traveling there.
There is just a certain vibe, a certain distrust that happens in that state and it's not worth
your time, okay.
I'm telling you right now, if you're starting from scratch, do not go into California.
If you're going to get dinged on, you know, oh, your licensing isn't done or you don't
have this on your site or whatever, it's going to be in California, mark my words.
So if you have not built sites already, avoid the state.
Not because I don't like it.
I've got friends that live there, I go there a couple of times a year, we've got Disneyland
season passes baby, I'll go there all day long.
But for business, for this type of stuff, avoid California.
I don't know how much I need to emphasize that.
And also if you have projects, if you live there and have projects, it's okay.
You can still make money.
I'm just telling you going forward, okay.
So what you're going to do is you're going to go here, you're going to type in your main
term and you're going to select a state.
Now one word of caution, one little thing I want to mention when you're selecting a
state is think about this year round.
I don't want, you know, a really, really cold state where it's going to get icy blizzard
cold and no one can pour concrete.
So for example, I'm probably not going to hit South Dakota, okay.
It's going to do really well in the summer, maybe okay in the spring, good in the spring,
good in the fall.
In winter, I'm going to lose my client, okay.
Or I'm going to have to really do some kind of a deal where they stay on with me.
So what I like to do is I like to go through these top states and I like to look at ones
just intuitively, okay, that one's not as cold, right.
So for example, like Utah, I know it's really cold in some parts of state, but where I live,
it never gets cold.
So there's literally the city I live in never gets cold.
I have palm trees, people have swimming pools, it's stucco, okay.
Tennessee that'd be a great example.
That one gets cold, but not crazy cold.
South Carolina, decent, right, or I don't know, not Oregon.
North Carolina would be okay, but it still gets kind of cold.
But I'm talking more like the Florida's, right.
Florida never gets cold, relatively speaking.
Nevada never gets cold, relatively speaking.
Texas does get cold, but not as bad.
It's not like, you know, there's always snow.
So just keep that in mind.
And what I'm going to do is I want you guys to, I'm going to tell you the state I'm going
to go into, but I just want to give you ideas.
This is a good way to narrow down states and give you ideas.
What you can do is once you select a state, you can then, if you want city ideas, you
can actually click on the state and typically it will tell you the highest searched cities
or areas within that state, which is a really cool thing to do, okay.
But you also can, can rest assured that if there's a lot of searching, there's probably
a lot of competition.
So what I want you to do is just use this tool to pick a state.
And for this example, for this training, I'm going to use the state of Arizona.
Why?
I live close to it.
Utah does kind of I've been there.
I have multiple projects there.
It's warm most of the time.
I love that because I don't have to worry about on and off and everything else.
And I've had really good luck with contractors.
I'm going to choose Arizona for concrete.
And so what I want you to do is once you select your state, I want you to go type in, you
know, Arizona cities by population.
Okay.
And you're going to just click on one of the links.
Doesn't matter.
And what I want you to do from there is go down and start about like the 50,000 or so
population.
Okay.
I want to work from the bottom up because I want to go.
Guys, I want you to realize this.
I want to choose the smallest population city that still meets the minimum requirements
for demand.
And that's the city I want to target because think about all the big guys, think about
the big companies, the big budgets and the big crews and all the money.
They want to go into the big cities.
Right.
So in Arizona, you know what they want to go into?
They want Phoenix.
They want Tucson.
They want Mesa.
They want Flagstaff.
Whatever.
I don't know.
I don't even know what Flagstaff is.
They want the big cities that you can see on the map.
I don't.
I want cities.
No one's looking at.
I want to be obscure with my city selection because no one's doing it.
And I'm going to kind of cheat the system here because I know a city that's going to
crush it because I've got other projects and other niches in the city.
But I want to show you what I would do.
So from here, what you would do is you would select cities starting at 50 K and you would
work your way up.
So we're going to take Maricopa and you're going to go back over to your tool and you're
going to type in your main keyword or one of them and then type in the city and state
abbreviation.
Okay.
So Concrete Contractors Maricopa, Arizona.
And we're going to see if it pulls any volume and it does 50.
Great.
Awesome.
We're good to go and we're just going to leave it.
Then we're going to go to the next one.
Okay.
So the next one is going to be Catalina Foothills.
So I'm going to go over here.
Sam Rush.
I'm going to type in Concrete Contractors.
Catalina Foothills AZ.
Did I spell that right?
Probably not.
Catalina.
Yes, I did.
Okay.
Now, if you do the first term, don't give up.
Do some variation.
So try just Concrete.
Okay.
Nothing.
Try getting rid of Arizona.
Be careful when you get rid of this abbreviation because sometimes multiple cities, there's
the same name city multiple states.
Make sure you're not looking at the wrong state.
I'll try doing Catalina Foothills Concrete, you know, opposite order.
And I'm just not seeing anything.
I'll try one more.
Okay.
So this one's kind of one of those where I'm just going to assume there's not a ton of
volume.
Okay.
And so I'm going to just, it is what it is.
Next one.
And this is the one that I'm going to actually go into, which is Queen Creek.
I've built projects here.
This is an up and coming city.
I've got this like information from clients.
They're like, this city is growing like crazy.
It's awesome.
It's going to keep expanding.
So I'm, I already knew before I did this, this was going to be a good city.
And so I did concrete Queen Creek, Arizona.
Lo and behold, there's 30 volume and we are good to go.
So what I want you to look at, I'm going to type in concrete contractors, Queen Creek AZ.
So it doesn't pull a lot for the concrete contractors.
Let me do concrete patio.
No, let's try Queen Creek concrete.
Okay.
We know there's a term.
Give me a sec here.
Okay.
Concrete.
So the only one that's pulling volume is the concrete Queen Creek.
So that's something to note is it does pull volume, but it's lower than Bentonville concrete
and it doesn't pull volume for every term, but it might just be the perfect one.
So then what you're going to do is now we've looked at a couple of cities and you guys,
you might have to do this for 10.
Okay.
You're going to want to do this at least five, uh, probably five to 10 cities and you're
just going to look at the cities and just see what they say when you add the city and the state
abbreviation to the end of the term.
Okay.
So I want you to start at the 50 K population, work your way up and see which cities do that.
And then what I want you to do guys is you're going to select the city based on the following.
You're going to look at these and here's the criteria that it has to match.
Yes, it has to have volume.
I recommend it having volume within at least 10 of what Bentonville concrete had, which
Bentonville concrete was 40.
So this one right here is it's got to be at least within 10 or, or more.
Right.
So this one fits the bill because it's 50.
This one does not fit the bill because it's zero and this one fits the bill because it's
really close.
It's 30, but here's the kicker.
And this is something I've talked about over and over and over again.
We have to pay attention to the cost per click.
This is the CPC.
For those of you that don't know what that is, that is when you go to Google and you
type in concrete Phoenix.
And these people at the top, you see how this says ad.
And I know some of you guys like this is very basic guys, just relax.
It's something to remind everyone about.
You see how these say ads.
These right here, people are paying per click.
That's why it's cost per click.
So me as a consumer, if I click on this ad right now, if I push click, which I'm not
going to do, it is going to charge this company, whatever the amount it costs in Phoenix.
So if we want to look, this is probably not going to be 100% accurate, but let's just
look for fun.
So let's just do concrete Phoenix.
And it's going to be higher, I would assume, than the other ones.
Actually, it's not bad, believe it or not.
Not bad.
374.
I'm actually really shocked, but you know what else is interesting?
There's only 30 people searching for it.
That's weird.
Okay, go to concrete companies in Phoenix.
You got 210, ton of volume, and it's got CPC, but here's what you also got to realize.
You also have to have your intuition play into this and realize these tools aren't
necessarily accurate.
Guys, everyone's going to want to rank for Phoenix.
I promise you that.
And so I'm just telling you, when we go into the next steps, which is actually assessing
and looking at the competition, my intuition tells me it's probably going to be really
competitive.
So you're going to look at these different cities and you're going to make sure, and
you're going to find one that has at least within 10 or more of what Bentonville Concrete
is, which is 40 search volume, according to SEMrush on this tool.
And then you got to make sure it has a CPC of less than $5, but more than zero.
If the CPC is $0, $0 cost per click, you can safely assume that that traffic is worth
nothing because no one else wants it.
So why would I, right?
So for example, in this one, yeah, cool.
There's 50 people searching for it.
It says, but no one's actually bidding on it.
No one's paying for clicks, which tells me it's probably worth nothing.
So I've, and I've tested this, guys, you're not going to get like, for some reason, it
just doesn't work.
So if it says zero, it doesn't work.
If it says 10, it typically doesn't work.
And I'm telling you right now, if I was doing Bentonville Concrete today, I would repeat
this.
I would not go into Bentonville Concrete today, but when I'm telling you, when I did this
a couple of years ago, it was like two bucks.
Okay.
Now, luckily I'm ranked organically, so this doesn't matter, but I would not be going into
Bentonville Concrete today.
When I did a couple of years ago, it was not this competitive.
Okay.
Thanks to me, it is.
So from these searches, we are now going to identify two or three cities that have volume.
Excuse me.
They have volume that's within 10 of Bentonville Concrete or whatever city you choose that's
got at least 30, 40, 50 leads per month or more, and it has a CPC of less than $5, but
greater than zero.
Okay.
So quick, quick, quick, quick recap.
Number one, you are going to go and you're going to pick a tool.
Step one.
Okay.
Doesn't matter what it is.
Paid, free, don't care.
You're going to go figure out what the baseline is.
What I mean by that is pick a project that's ranking that you know is getting leads and
it's been getting leads for years and years organically, and you know how many leads it's
getting.
If you don't have one, use Bentonville Concrete and figure out how that compares to what the
tool says.
That's your baseline.
Okay.
So that's number two.
Step three is you're going to use Google Trends to identify a state to start with.
Okay.
If you have a state in mind, awesome, but if you don't know and you're in a new niche
or whatever, go pick a state.
From there, you're going to type into Google state plus cities in population with population,
order of population, whatever.
So Arizona cities by population.
Utah cities by population.
And you're going to then start at 50,000, go to the bottom, start at 50,000, put those
into your tool with the city and state variation and find
cities where it pulls at least what Bentonville Concrete pulls or it's within 10 or more.
And it has a CPC of less than $5 and more than zero.
And guys, if you can find two or three cities with it meet those metrics following that
system, you have got three potential, two to three potential cities that you are going
to go and make money on.
And that is what you're going to do to start.
And next guys, what we're going to do next is we're going to go and we're going to dig
into that city.
We're going to analyze that city.
We're going to do the market research on that city before we just start building.
Do those steps.
See you in the next video.